what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some major Deadpool 3
news and it looks like we know most of
the main cast who is going to be in this
movie and we also have a good idea of
what the plot is going to be what cameos
to expect and how exactly Deadpool is
going to be making his way over to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and who he
plans on taking with him and I have a
theory on how exactly this is going to
sort of fuse with Secret Wars and fall
into place perfectly with the storyline
now we do have sort of a plot synopsis
for Deadpool 3 that was shared by a
Marvel actor we'll jump into that in
just a bit but first let's go over who
the current cast is for Deadpool 3
because they just added some new members
one of which is an X-Men and if you love
Marvel and want to stay up to date be
sure to hit that subscribe button and of
course we're doing a giveaway and the
winner gets the choice of a PS5 an Xbox
series X some Marvel Legends gear or
some DC items as well the winner gets to
pick just subscribe and leave a comment
down below we pick a winner at the end
of each month so like I mentioned we
have some new castings for Deadpool 3.
one of which is an X-Men and that's
right we are talking about Colossus
Stefan kapik is confirmed to be
returning to play the role of Colossus
and also it has been confirmed as of
today that Miranda bakarin is returning
to play Vanessa Deadpool's girlfriend
now with this you have to remember that
at the end of Deadpool 3 Deadpool did
take Cable's time travel device after he
fixed it and went back in time and
changed a lot this is going to heavily
tie into Secret Wars and the TVA is
going to be on Deadpool about this in
Deadpool 3. we'll talk about that in
just a bit but the main takeaway is that
Vanessa is now alive Deadpool went back
in time and prevented her from dying
well from being murdered he ends up
killing that person first before she
gets murdered creating a new timeline
one in which she is now alive also
something that is going to play a big
role in Deadpool 3 as well is the fact
that he went back in time and
essentially killed himself possibly
having some pretty big effects on other
timelines as well now he went back in
time and communicated with Wolverine and
at the time that was just going to be a
joke but now they're going to weave this
into the story of Deadpool 3 because
right now as far as we know this is the
cast so far Ryan Reynolds of course
playing Deadpool Hugh Jackman the man
returning to play Wolverine the
Wolverine and some variants of Wolverine
as well he already confirmed this
himself personally thank you Kevin feige
Love You Kevin feige so we'll see some
other Wolverines played by Hugh Jackman
and maybe some Wolverines that aren't
played by Hugh Jackman perhaps Taran
eagerton shows up for Cameo just for fun
nothing serious but maybe just for fun
in a random universe that Deadpool and
Wolverine visit then of course as I
mentioned we have Stefan kapik returning
as Colossus Marina bakarin returning as
Vanessa and Quran Sony returning as
dopinder he's a great character really
glad he's returning and also Leslie
oogums is returning as blind Al so
Deadpool's friends and sword of his
family are going to be a part of
Deadpool 3. now Matthew McFadden is also
going to be a part of Deadpool 3 however
the role he is going to play has not
been disclosed yet it's also been
confirmed that Emma Corin is going to be
joining the Deadpool 3 movie and there
are rumors going around right now that
she could possibly be playing x-23 now
take this with a huge grain of salt I
think these rumors are more just
speculation at this point in time on who
she could be playing but I definitely
think it would be pretty dang cool to
see x-23 show up however if they are
going to kind of take Wolverine away
from the Logan timeline I would also
expect to see Daphne Keane show up who
played Laura Kinney AKA x23 in Logan and
I think she did an incredible job but
remember Multiverse Deadpool and
Wolverine are going to be visiting a lot
of different universes and as far as we
know so far it's just going to be
Deadpool and Wolverine Marine visiting
these other universes not all of the
other cast that was mentioned and like I
said we do kind of have a little bit of
a plot synopsis coming from a Marvel
actor Lewis tan who played shatterstar
in Deadpool 2 for a very brief moment
because as we know he died pretty
quickly I mean they all died pretty
quickly but again Deadpool did go back
and seemingly he stopped some of their
deaths at least so a Twitter account
called Marvel updates posted this in
Deadpool 3 Deadpool will use Cable's
time travel machine to save Wolverine
before his death in 2029 and they end up
lost in the Multiverse being pursued by
Mobius well Louis Tan replied to this
tweet with a bunch of emojis kind of
hinting that yeah this is pretty much
true and this is actually what we pretty
much assumed to be true in the first
place anyways Deadpool 3's post-credit
scenes tie into the MCU what they're
doing with the Multiverse Saga so well
it's like they planned it before which
could be possible after all Marvel's
Studio's president Kevin feige said they
usually have about 10 years planned for
the MCU he said what they have already
announced they have six plus additional
years planned for after that so about a
total of 10 years planned ahead and at
the time of Deadpool 2 that was kind of
when the fox Disney deal was happening
so perhaps they kind of planned that out
but maybe not maybe it's just a
coincidence and if it is it's a great
coincidence so I'm assuming that
Deadpool has this device he changes
things to make it to where his life is
pretty much perfect however what is he
missing he's missing that one true best
friend Wolverine who he's already come
in contact with in the post credits for
Deadpool 2. so here's where my Theory
comes in I assume that Deadpool is going
to be trying to set up his perfect life
he's going to have his friends he's
going to have Vanessa his girlfriend
right beside him then he's going to
maybe get in close with the X-Men and
then realize that he doesn't have his
best friend Wolverine so he's going to
leave whatever current timeline he set
up that has everything thing that he
wants in it and he's gonna go to the
Logan timeline and this is where he
pretty much just takes him however at
this point in time Wolverine might kind
of put up a fight and during this battle
Deadpool might grab Wolverine and try to
take him to a different timeline but the
time travel device gets damaged this is
how they end up getting lost in the
Multiverse The Time Machine device could
start malfunctioning therefore giving
Deadpool no control over it because
based off of what we saw in the post
credit for Deadpool 2 he definitely knew
how to work the machine so as far as
them getting lost it would make sense
that the time travel device would get
broken in some type of way not fully
broken because it's very clear that they
still are going to be traveling
different timelines throughout the
Multiverse but broken enough to where he
can't fully control where he is going
now when this happens it is going to be
just pure chaos we know Deadpool we know
he doesn't really care about much so
that whole don't leave any Trail in a
new timeline don't step on a butterfly
because of the butterfly effect etc etc
he probably doesn't care about that at
all in fact we know he doesn't because
he he has already gone and messed with
several timelines already so Deadpool is
going to continue to mess with
essentially the entire Multiverse
because we know that starting just a few
new timelines that could start an entire
multiversal war and obviously we do not
want another multiversal War and who is
responsible for that well the TVA they
are responsible for making sure that
doesn't happen and who is rumored to be
in this movie Mobius and Miss minutes so
of course we would expect Mobius to be
pursuing Deadpool as he goes around the
Multiverse messing things up and here's
where the really cool part of Deadpool 3
comes in Deadpool visiting these other
universes because we have reports
already stating that the original X-Men
characters the original X-Men actors
from the fox X-Men Trilogy the first one
they're all going to be appearing in
Deadpool 3. there's also been a report
that the original Fantastic Four are
going to be appearing in Deadpool 3 as
well with Jessica Alba and I will
absolutely lose my mind when this
happens now however here is where I
think the actual plot will differ a
little bit from what was posted I'm not
sure about Wolverine being taken from
the Logan timeline Hugh Jackman already
stated that they aren't going to undo
the death of Logan so either one of two
things is going to happen one is that
they simply take Wolverine from a
different timeline that way they truly
don't undo the death of Logan by taking
him away from that timeline or two they
take him away from that timeline and
then ultimately end up returning him to
that timeline where he will eventually
go on to die but here's the deal I think
all of these other X-Men characters that
were going to be seen in Deadpool 3 are
making their way over to the MCU we
basically know that Deadpool 3 is going
to end with him in the MCU but there
have been many reports that state the
original X-Men characters and Fantastic
Four possibly as well are indeed going
to be in secret Wars and this just makes
sense Secret Wars is essentially going
to be like Deadpool we're going to
explore many different universes and
many different heroes from these
universes are going to come together to
fight Kang and of course the X-Men are
going to be a part of that however these
are not going to be new X-Men characters
entering the MCU they're going to be the
old X-Men characters we know that the
new X-Men aren't coming to the MCU until
after the Multiverse Saga in fact the
next Saga is probably going to be the
mutant Saga so I don't think they're
gonna take Hugh Jackman's Wolverine from
the Logan timeline and then return him I
think they're gonna get him from a
different timeline and Deadpool's gonna
drag him to the MCU so he can take part
in secret Wars the only question is at
this point in time is who else is going
to be going with him is Vanessa going
with him is dopinder going with him or
are they only going to be in the
beginning of this movie where Deadpool
has everything that he wants and then he
leaves to go get Wolverine and the rest
of the movie is him in Wolverine jumping
universes until they eventually make
their way into the MCU and that's where
they stay this probably is the case but
for the sake of Deadpool kind of getting
a happy ending here perhaps he makes his
way to the MCU at some point in time
during Deadpool 3 and decides that that
is where he wants to be well then he
could go back to his original universe
or I should say the new one that he's
kind of created for himself with all of
his loved ones and take them into the
MCU that way Deadpool kind of gets
everything that he wants he gets his
loved ones he gets Vanessa and he gets
Wolverine all in the universe that he
wants to be a part of the universe with
the Avengers also the universe or at
least a universe close to the one that
Loki who is a part of the TVA now kind
of got taken from so Mobius might allow
him to actually stay in our main MCU
timeline because they're gonna need him
to fight Kang so this is how I think
Deadpool and Wolverine make their way to
the MCU but go ahead and let me know
your thoughts about that in the comments
down below please don't forget to like
the video and of course subscribe to
stay up to date on the MCU and to enter
our giveaway you can always follow us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof